Speaker 1: There is a very disturbing video
of police aggressively arresting an eight
year old for allegedly stealing a bag of potato
chips in Syracuse, New York.
Now, originally, this story was reported as
a 10 year old boy that was being really treated
like an adult for allegedly stealing a bag
of potato chips.
We have since learned that this is actually,
as of right now, believed to be an eight year
old.
Could that also be wrong?
Maybe.
But as far as we know right now, this is an
eight year old.
I'm going to play the video.
The video is disturbing, not in a gory sense.
It's just disturbing in terms of how these
police officers are treating this kid.
Let's take a look
Speaker 4: at what you're doing.
OK?
Are you like a baby to me, baby?
That's what I'm doing.
I don't know what you doing.
I just think it's matching, you know?
So what's the what's going on in you stealing
stuff?
If you break into your house to steal something,
maybe inside a bag of chips, we got really
like a whole cold blooded killer.
He can keep walking.
Do you don't even know you're going to do
that?
You know what?
I just came up to see a neighbor.
I just came up here saying, OK, what you see,
I see, just like you, don't ask me.
And he said, All right, now
Speaker 1: the kid is black and we, I mean,
we have to consider the racial component here.
And I told the story on our livestream yesterday
when I was, I think I was like 10 or 11, and
my little brother was eight or nine.
We went grocery shopping and we get home.
And I remember this like it was yesterday
because it was so notable to me.
We got home and my brother pulls out a king
sized Snickers bar.
Not even the normal size.
This is the big boy, you know, it's like it.
It's like a huge steel rod, you know, the
king sized Snickers.
And my mom said to my brother, Sir, where
did you get that?
Now she didn't call him sir.
She said, We're working to get that.
And he says the grocery store.
And what do you mean?
Where was it?
It was at the checkout.
You know, I got it and my mom explained, No,
no.
We can't do that.
That's stealing.
You can't do that.
And to teach the lesson, they went back to
the grocery store and they said he took this
and we didn't pay for it.
So we're coming back to return it.
And, you know, management was like, Oh, thank
you so much for being honest.
You know what?
For your honesty.
Go ahead and keep it.
And I think my mom insisted on paying for
it.
Then, you know, to teach a lesson and whatever.
And it was really notable, and it sticks out
in my mind and it was like, this is the way
that things are supposed to be done.
Imagine if police were involved for that for
the Snickers.
Speaker 4: It would.
It would just be outrageous.
Speaker 1: It wouldn't be.
It wouldn't be justice.
It wouldn't be educational.
It wouldn't be something that would point
my brother in the right direction when it
comes to a place.
I mean, there's just no upside to handling
it in that way.
Now, my brother wasn't black at the time.
He's still not black.
In fact, some people might be shocked that
he's still not black.
So obviously we have this question of the
racial component.
Would this would this situation have been
handled the same way if a white kid had stole
a jelly bean or whatever the case may be?
We can't say because there are two different
situations, but it certainly doesn't look
good.
We've now heard from the, you know, this is
the wrong story.
We've now heard from the mayor of Syracuse
who weighed in.
This is Mayor Ben Walsh and said that he was
concerned when he saw a boy put in the back
of a cruiser after allegedly stealing a bag
of chips.
And the mayor said from what he saw, the boy
wasn't placed in handcuffs, the officer knew
the child from prior interactions and explained
to him he was being taken home.
The officers returned the child to his family
and discussed the incident before leaving
without filing any charges.
So it seems as though the perspective they're
taking is sort of like, Well, listen, he wasn't
cuffed, he wasn't arrested.
He wasn't charged.
He was just basically taken home and explained,
you know, he was.
It was explained to him why what he did was
wrong.
But the man handling is absolutely absurd.
Even the placing in the back of the police
car, I mean, listen again.
When I was growing up, when an officer got
involved in one of these, let me help, right?
Let me be the positive influence.
You put the kid in the front right and now
you could say, well, but sometimes the police
cars have the laptops in the front.
The entire handling is, wow, this is a criminal.
And unfortunately, this is exactly the type
of thing that can point people kids to adversarial
perspectives with police.
It can point them in the direction of repeating
these actions in the future.
It's all horrible.
Now, meanwhile, earlier in the week I mentioned
there was a shooting in Syracuse, and it's
not like there is a shortage of other stuff
police can be involved in.
There were like four officers involved, at
least with this eight year old kid.
We now have learned that a Syracuse man has
been arrested in that Armory Square shooting
that I told you about from over the weekend.
And so it's not even a case of like there
is nothing else to do in Syracuse.
It's not a direct line where like, if these
four officers weren't, you know, taking this
kid into custody or whatever that they would
have been involved in solving or preventing
that shooting, OK, I get that.
But there is not a sort of there's nothing
for police to be doing in Syracuse sort of
situation.
So let me know your thoughts.
Many people outraged over this.
Some saying the police handled it fine.
That's not my perspective.
But I would love to hear from you.
You can find me on Twitter
at Packman.